i'm bob odenkirk and this is how i
became
hutch
hutch mansell is a regular
dad guy suburbanite fella
you pass on the street and you barely
notice him and that's exactly
what he intended to be because he's
kind of in hiding he actually has a past
a violent past
but that was all before he got married
and had some
kids and wanted a normal
normal life like a regular old joe
he's been hiding in this character of
hutch
and suffering as he's been doing it
for a long time he's a accountant he
works
at his father-in-law's factory tool and
dye factory
and he kind of feels like he's
disappearing
and then there is a home invasion
and it kind of sparks a lot of anger and
rage inside him
and he goes off and reconnects with his
violent past
and in doing so he creates
more problems for himself and he's
forced
to carry on beating the living [ __ ]
out of people everybody get to the
basement
what is happening don't call 9-1-1
the spark of the idea for nobody came uh
from me and a number of different things
influenced it
one of them being i'm 58 now but i was
54 when i
had the notion that as a dad you really
start to feel like you're disappearing a
little bit
especially as you get older well i mean
the whole world becomes about the
younger generation
and in my case my kids are now their
20s but they were teenagers and you
start to really kind of disappear a
little bit you feel like you're not that
important anymore and that's hard to
take
and then uh on top of that we had a
couple home invasions in my home we
actually had two
in the course of just a few years and
they were pretty disconcerting
and uh we kept things i kept things cool
until the police arrived but i always
wondered if i could have done more
did you even take a swing no could have
taken her dad
and there's even a certain residue of
rage and anger that you have
after that kind of violation of your
home
uh so that feeling that i had inside me
but also i was inspired by the fact that
better call saul
plays around the world it plays well in
russia and china and italy and
romania and latin america and i thought
it'd be neat if i could do a movie that
would play around the world and i know
action films do so
all those things taken together
made me think what is an action movie
and a story that i could do and i
thought
what about a guy who's really
disappeared himself
hidden himself away in the guise of a
normal suburban
dad and he's done it for a long period
of time
and he's got whatever rage or
frustration i have
times 50. i wish they'd have picked my
place you know
listen i'm surrounded by the best in the
business on nobody
the fact that derek colstad who wrote
john wick
wanted to write it he's writing the best
action films that are
playing right now ilyan nye schuler who
directed it directed hardcore henry
he is action genre lover
like nobody else on earth he knows every
action movie and sequence and he's just
a great director does
beautiful imagery does these amazing
music videos
cool guy russian guy david leach
led our pack along with kelly mccormick
david and kelly together
surrounded me with the best stunt people
and my training
was done by the best stunt
actor in the world daniel bernhardt
remember that name you've seen him in
atomic blonde he
he fights charlize in that apartment
scene you
loved him in barrie last year when he
played the
karate expert guy daniel's been in every
of
every great action movie of the last 20
years
he trained me for two years this guy
showed extreme patience with me as i
learned
to throw a fake punch
but david leach you know leading the way
i mean we couldn't ask for anyone better
i i was surrounded by pros
which is why the the action sequences
in nobody are as good as they are
i'm gonna [ __ ] you up well my favorite
sequence in the movie
action sequence is the first big one and
it's in a bus
where my character takes on like eight
different guys
at once and what i loved about that was
it was close up hand to hand and
had to be really choreographed and
practiced and we all had to work
together
it was a real expression of like pure
intense rage which i guess i've been
wanting to get out of me for
my whole [ __ ] life it was hard to do
it was a real tester to see if i could
even do this
well and you know i i thought about
jackie chan movies i love his early
films police story is one of my favorite
movies
and i wanted to get in there and do that
kind of work and that's what i trained
for for two and a half years
and that bus fight was uh a challenge
a danger and a joy to do
and i hope people like it half as much
as i love
making it
we rehearsed in a taped off area
with pads everywhere and
then we rehearsed a little bit on the
bus but the truth is the actual bus has
you know all these metal poles
around you and little sharp edges that
you
you don't rehearse around those things
so
yeah i got hurt a little but it was only
from hitting my arms or hands on things
but nothing structural
the hardest thing about doing nobody for
me was the lack of
irony i'm used to being very silly or
playing a character who's a little bit
ironically aware of themselves this guy
was earnest
in a 70s action movie way and that's
what i wanted
so i deprived myself of that ironic
dimension and that was
very hard for me as a person i'm just
used to making fun of the world
and myself in it i didn't get that
outlet here saying these cold-blooded
intense action movie lines
was challenging for me and a joy and i
know they make people laugh
and i'm gonna laugh when i see them
because it's a thrill
and you love to hear that impactful line
and i also think what's great about
especially that line on the bus where i
say i'm going to [ __ ] you
up is you kind of go i don't think you
are
and you can see it in my eyes and i put
it there
i hope uh the character isn't sure if
he's
gonna deliver on that promise and he
hasn't done this in 20
25 years that's our story that's our
backstory for the character so he's not
sure he's
gonna [ __ ] these guys up he's just
committing to doing it
so i loved seeing those lines i
committed to
to playing the part uh sans irony
it was challenging but i knew it would
be and i was
down for it down for the challenge of it
the last guy anyone wants to see at
their door
because it meant you didn't have long to
live
this guy's had this [ __ ] sitting
festering inside him for a long time
and it kind of makes sense coming out of
an older
character that degree of unbridled rage
whereas a younger person you might feel
more deranged
but in this case it feels maybe slightly
more justified by life
like life just putting you down and i
think that maybe everybody can
can feel relate to that and when i say
everybody i mean even women who go
yeah i'd like to fight back once in my
life
you look like [ __ ] dad you should see
the other guys when i suggested the idea
of myself in an action movie
that everyone would laugh at me and tell
me to
go back to reading whatever book i was
reading
at the time i was surprised that when i
pitched it to people
who should know better and i said
you know i play an earnest guy and
better call saul i play a guy who wants
things and fails and wants them again
and doesn't quit and whose feelings are
hurt
i mean they're really hurt and i think
it's kind of like an action
character except he's not fighting
that's the only difference
and they said yeah you're right and i
kind of got that response from a bunch
of
people i was very surprised because i
was fully
prepared for people to laugh laugh at me
in the face
and tell me to skedaddle
who the [ __ ] are you me
i'm nobody
[Music]